well this occurred to me oh i don't like
i don't like whatever's happening right
now i have been experiencing and people
are fascinated in our culture with let's
i want to know behind the scenes what's
really going on with with our biggest
stars
what's it really like to be them uh well
let me open up a window for you and tell
you
because
um i think it's fair to say that i'm a
big deal oh yeah i know i'm up there
with the uh i'm the timothy chalamet of
comedy if you will wow
well i think that's fair he's so young
and so what's in about i didn't say
anything about my age or i know i feel
really bad the second young came out i
felt really bad that's what i'm talking
about i'm saying i am i think most
people right now listening to the
podcast are nodding if you said to them
what's conan i think a lot of people
would say he's the timothee chalamet
of comedy but what it what is it that
you guys have in common um just this
we're omnipresent we're everywhere
uh you know try and avoid conor o'brien
in the culture and try and avoid timothy
chalamet not gonna happen right any time
you
turn up a volume uh dial you're gonna
hear me
i'm everywhere do you think that your
podcast right now is like as talked
about as the movie dune yes
oh you do yeah oh okay i think it's
probably up there with i bet i'm i'm not
having checked to see if i'm trending
and i don't encourage anyone to check
i think just please don't check yeah but
i bet dunes trending chalamet is
trending
and uh that conan guy is trending am i
zendaya
no
that's ridiculous i pronounce that right
i hear she's hardly in the movie yeah
she's in like 10 minutes i haven't seen
it yet but she's in she's everywhere and
i thought oh this is the story of
timothy chalamet and zendaya yeah uh you
know on a sand planet and uh no
apparently
i think she enters briefly looks at the
camera says zendaya present and then
walks out
present accounted for i think it's her
full line i'd be happy to be here anyway
i'm going to let you in on what it's
like to be me which is i've had a lot of
mouth discomfort
lately
oh this is how you're timothy chalamet
huh he talks about his mouth discomfort
all the time no he doesn't no of course
he's oh
oh that's sarcasm i just believe
anything sona ever tells me yeah that
was so oh i see it's sarcasm well guess
what yeah if he wants to stay relevant
he should let people in on what's going
on with himself medically i would tell
timothy shalamay uh that he should okay
tell people by the way
little known fact do you remember this
sona yeah a couple of years ago we did
uh shows at comic-con
and a good friend of mine brought
uh his nephew
to our after party yeah it was timothy
chalamet about
i want to say a year before he blew up
wow or a year and a half maybe two years
uh yeah i think i i know what you're
saying and he hung out at our after
party and i have a picture of me
with timothy and i'm like yeah he seems
like a nice kid i'll give him a little
picture he can he's gonna treasure this
his whole life yeah this picture with
conan o'brien get in here kid here's
something you can hang on to for the
rest of your life this is your biggest
moment right now your picture with conan
o'brien yeah click
he's the biggest star in the universe
oscar nominee yeah and uh you know what
am i over here chopped liver yes i am
but anyway that's not my point my point
is
to get across
that i knew timothee chalamet just
before he blew up and some would say i'm
responsible
others would say
there's no connection right and he owes
me nothing that's probably the more
logical explanation what's happening
with your health my health i've had this
and i'm letting you in
on a big star's pain in agony i have had
this discomfort in my mouth that really
i swear to god was a tooth
a bad tooth so i went to the dentist
they took x-rays nothing wrong a couple
of weeks later it's still really
bothering me i go back more x-rays they
look they go no nothing's wrong and then
one of them said you know what your
sinus cavity
is very close to the tooth nerve have
you had a cold lately yes i have
so then i look up online
nasal
uh swelling tooth pain
and it comes back
i know
that's what people want to hear about
on his google searches that's some sex
hey you want to hear about my sexy
google search
check this out
nasal inflammation mouth
pain milf
i put milk i put milf in at the end
no yes i did
and man was i off to the race oh
anyway uh just if you're out there uh
it's a real thing
and then it's suggested take a
decongestant and see what happens i took
a decongestant tooth pain went away
completely
and so i'm gonna get it checked out i'm
gonna see an ent and get this sinus
thing worked out yeah but i just want
you to know
well i just let you in i made myself
vulnerable
and i think that's pretty uh brave well
and if you're out there and you're
suffering from a toothache and you're
going to the dentist and they're saying
there's nothing wrong
it could be a sinus thing right you're
saving savings lives okay all right i
get it
i get it
the joke is on me sexy googling about
sinus infections i
you know what i would just milf to every
google search i just add milk to
everything i really do oh yeah i do um
battle of lexington concord
1775 milf
and you will see
very attractive women in their 40s
um naked uh fighting it out with the
british
naked yeah oh
would you think a milf search they're
not they're wearing what you think
they're wearing bee keepers outfits
what are you talking about
i don't know well you have to also put
naked oh you obviously milf
yeah sometimes i forget the naked and i
do just lexington conquered
um battle 1775 naked and it's
a naked male recreation
of that battle and that's not i have to
say
it's just not fun it doesn't do it for
you it doesn't do it for me yeah but
let's review yeah what we've learned in
this incredible opening so that was
completely unscripted
one uh if you have mouth pain it could
be your sinus just check into that yes
and if you want temporary relief use a
decongestant
uh
two
timothy chalamet
uh the biggest thing that may ever have
happened to him is his picture with me
right which i'm sure he treasures i've
seen some photographs of him because
there's photographs of him everywhere
and he's wearing a locket i bet it's the
photo of me
and him in the locket oh
i'm pretty sure that's the kira member
is taking that picture with you i think
uh no
i bet he died quite certain i'm quite
certain he has no memory of anything
that happened to him when he's got the
kind of fame where everything that
happened to you before that fame started
is completely obliterated
it's like men in black his when you get
that kind of fame all memory prior to
that is wiped clean yeah that's the okay
yeah i get that i know that i'm not that
famous because i remember everything
really well i was just gonna ask if you
remember anything before you were 29. no
a super
very detailed granular memories of fifth
grade
uh and all the humiliations and
struggles with acne all still there in
brilliant technicolor so yes wow i never
quite made it um but i've talked to
people like tom hanks and i've said so
you know uh before splash and he's like
nothing wow no memory
and and then steve martin no memory
betty white's real fame came later in
life she has no memory of anything that
happened to her before she was 85. so he
won't remember having ice cream with me
at ghirardelli
who timothy timothy imagine if he
remembered sona but didn't remember you
could we have him on the podcast
are you guys do you have his number are
you close no i don't have his number
uh i could probably get it but no i i
don't have his number i'm sure you know
what i'm gonna say sona
sure i'm gonna be nice to you yes i'm
sure he remembers having ice cream with
you okay he probably remembers exactly
what he ordered peppermint fudge ripple
crunch
[Music]